[Musik]
die tote oma ja das gericht titel wurst
hatten wir so genannt das ist
umgangssprachlich ja nico hatte das aber
wörtlich genommen es nicht aus
deutschland ist mir leid ich war
ängstlich ich dachte oma inge wäre
wirklich etwas passiert du wirst
herrlich nico ja das alles ist uns
wirklich sehr peinlich und bedauern sehr
dass sie kommen mussten aber das war
keine böse absicht
nein das hätte jedem passieren kann also
jedem der die sprache nicht kennt
eigentlich sollten wir dankbar sein
er hat zivilcourage bewiesen er hatte
sich sorgen gemacht genau eigentlich ist
es gar nicht nein nicht wenn jemand ist
gut meint john huston junghans war land
schauen junge frau junge frau und sie
machten nicht ganz verlegen
mir geht es gut dann hat schütz hat noch
acht sonntag wieder sehen wir sehen
[Musik]